foreign
[Music]
Nick Fury my favorite one-eyed man of
Entry how goes it out there I am cold No
Air
space
[Applause]
[Music]
you took everything from me
and now I'm returning the favor
thank you
what is happening to me
[Music]
she's entangled our light-based powers
so we switch places whenever we use them
you can absorb light
I can see it and Kamala who's Kamala hi
she can turn light into physical matter
which I have never heard of I could
totally show you no
ah
[Music]
stick around
he's targeting every planet we call home
I would never choose to bring anybody
into this
you are not the only thing standing
between this and the universe
[Music]
faster
I can't can you I got it
I am Groot
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
we've trained the best and brightest
young Heroes since 1965.
godolken is a safe space for you to
thrive
Marie Moreau you could be the first
top-ranked freshman in history I think
you meant to say first black woman in
seven
but you have a Target on your back a few
of us are going off campus let's have a
good time
[Music]
I'm still drunk from last night perfect
just take a sip say turbo Rush cures
hangovers I wouldn't pour this on my
giving cured cancer
there are dangerous evil people at that
school
[Music]
everything is
I exploded his tag team explosion wow
foreign
class is savages here
okay
[Music]
I want to fly let's do this
yeah
you got a force it to come out what are
you you're a genius I know like what'd I
say
did you know what was going to happen to
my brother when you stuck him with this
world destroying thing
it's called the Scarab
I had no idea it would activate it has
to choose you
[Music]
acquired who said that systems
protection
[Music]
we think the government is going to do
when they figure out that some kid has
this military attack
it belongs to me
[__]
listen to me
but I swear
the world is a place to protect you I
have an Arsenal at my disposal
whatever you can imagine
I can create yeah that's more like it
I love you feel for your family makes
you weak you're wrong for him that's
what makes me strong
oh I forgot how bad it looks
hero Cumberland
you're the Blue Beetle that could use
that Arsenal right about now I can never
ask oh yeah
press it down bust it down
I advise me back away
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
my son never show Mercy we
are predators
boys your mother is dead
she died because you sent her away she
was weak sick in her mind
you know my business yes
power is about strength
if you show weakness you will give our
enemies an opening
[Applause]
he's weak like his mother leave him
what happened that day
I stared death in the face and for the
first time I saw my true self
tell me about this Hunter
they say he uses a connection with
animals to track his prey
once you're on his list
there's only one way off it's six of us
and only one of you there's six of you
now
[Music]
why do you hunt my father puts evil into
the world
I take it out
[Music]
I think you're some guy on you are
exactly like our father just another man
hunting foreign
Mr tagline
Mr techlin
where's Mr tagley oh you're standing in
him
you're goddamn lunatic oh you just
figure that out now
there is an animal I need to run a fast
don't you want to know why they call me
the rhino
thank you
[Music]
will be
hello
we have a little bit of a situation we
wanted to run by you Mobius wow great to
see you again
[Applause]
that that's what's been happening wow
time slipping wait times you know that
yeah you've seen that yeah can you fix
that no
it's impossible to time slipping the TVA
I know but we just saw it happen
[Music]
pulled through time
between the past and the present hello
everyone I saw is true
there's nothing to stand between this
world and other destruction only one way
to find out
a little good old-fashioned legwork
listen we have different styles you're a
man of action which is fine
I take a more slow deliberate cerebral
approach
it's really good buy
[Music]
it's up to us
to save this place is this cracked yeah
whatever we do
we're playing God
we are gods
but how do you how do you choose
who lives
and who dies
make the hard choice
is on its way
come on you're the god of mischief
always have been
always will be
well over the top don't you think I
thought it'd be spot on
hey everyone uh we're extremely sad to
have missed d23 but we've been working
very hard on the next Deadpool film for
uh a good long while now I've had to
really search my soul on this one his
first appearance in the MCU obviously
needs to feel special we need to stay
true to the character find new depth and
motivation and meaning every Deadpool
needs to stand out and stand apart
it's been an incredible challenge that
has forced me to reach down deep inside
and I have nothing
yeah
just completely
empty up here
and terrifying but we did have one idea
hey Hugh you want to play Wolverine one
more time
yeah sure
[Music]
[Applause]
hi my favorite little Merry band of
Misfits it's me Harley Quinn and you can
stop salivating because season four is
here so strap in for more sex more drama
more bang Bean Bane and more horror Ivy
like a lot more because you wear
weirdos anyways love you bye hey baby
you forgot your lunch
lunch
oh God We're Cute so damn cute good luck
with your first day
it's a bird
[Music]
geez sorry for trying to get a Vibe
going
there's my new CEO girl power and all
that stuff Lex hired a skirt
lean and disrupt and things of that
nature I'm heading to the Moon look the
rocket isn't shaped like a giant penis
[__] I hope the clouds don't have a gag
reflex
you're a good guy now okay so we kicking
his ass we're heroes we update records
and stay
so boring
yes a crime
to solve no one gets in the way of me
owning the game I'm working right now
yeah Harley if we're gonna make our new
jobs work we need to establish some
boundaries what are you wearing a
lanyard with a bunch of maps and QR
codes yes oh call me when you're in the
bathtub I want to hear more about this
[__] lanyard Harley Jesus it's just
too hard to integrate my new job into my
old life hey watch him party like we
used to
rugs out steal a car just to crash it
into an even nicer car
[Music]
oh you got that edge still
no killing I found you guys for not
telling me
[Music]
oh for Dick's sake
I'm pumping my calves women don't
understand the pressures put on men's
bodies
[__] gross
for some of you it probably seemed like
this day would never come
maybe you're even wondering if you're
ready for this
[Music]
for what comes next
you have no idea what I'm capable of
I didn't know who he was
because I would win never apologize for
saving lives there's only one way this
kid goes back out there and that's on a
very short leash I'm just happy helping
people
you know people try to kill us every
single day right I don't care how old he
is he needs to go down now
maybe if you train more and complained
less we could get back to saving lives
make them pay for what he did to your
world welcome son of he who slayed my
husband I am a normal human superhero I
wish he was dead too but not for your
sake kill fast and ask questions later
[Music]
feltramide against viltromite that has
not happened since the Great Purge
[Music]
you should have died at Birth
let me tell you something
I'm Star-Lord
I formed the Guardians
[Music]
metagirl fell in love
that girl died but then she came back
she came back in totaled dick oh please
he left out some important information
but
that is the gist of it
that I wouldn't go
my sacred mission
is to create the perfect Society
I didn't want to make things perfect
he just hated things the way they are
[Music]
I want you all to know that I'm grateful
to fight beside my friends
incinerate them
all right
we're always searching for a family
until we found each other
are you ready
for One Last Ride
we'll all fly away together
into the forever
beautiful sky
[Applause]
whoever it was that you were in love
with it sounds more like her hers do not
bring me into them
knock it off what
we're noticed how black your eyes were
they were replaced by my father as a
method of torture he he picked a pretty
set
laughs
sure
Since You've Been Gone
things have gotten much worse
oh you think I came back
[Music]
you're in no shape for this fight that
lies before us good friend
all right
this is personal
very few of us know about the wars
fought in the shadows that have raged on
this planet
[Music]
do you feel responsible
this war is one I have to fight alone
did man on the planet
you don't know what they have planned
for you
thank you
the Great Neck Fury
one last fight
oh my God
hi I love you thank you passing you into
Mr Wayne no please don't stop
Barry
so you're saying you can travel back in
time
but Bruce I can fix things I can save
people
I can save my mom save your parents
you can also destroy everything
I love you too so how was it this week
how's school school was good oh
this is mad trippy dude this is
catastrophic
this world must die
I'm not gonna lose there again
it's not Quark my name is Cara I will
help you
interesting groups lots of health
wait he's Batman
you want to get nuts let's get nuts
or in unguarded territory
we try not to die
are you ready ready let's go
[Music]
you have fancy friends
yo who's an Uber
exact
[Music]
ly
as you can see Metropolis has gone
positively Gotham since the Justice
League disappeared it's out of Trace but
we've been missing what do you call when
your Heroes need Heroes
he can fly in he's got his vision
now we can find out what happened to the
Justice League faster than a speeding
more powerful women locomotive just like
Superman
oh no we're sealed in all you have to do
is unmask this Phantom before all these
out of control villains destroy the
world
ah giganta
most Kryptonian exiles
Solomon Grundy
that's right
all right all right we have to look for
Clues
what's the point what's the point of any
of this why am I trapped in here with a
bunch of annoying kids
who's a good boy who's a good boy
[Music]
um
foreign
[Music]
welcome message
foreign
[Music]
systems
thank you
[Music]
something isn't right
I don't know what's going on
I need to find a way back yes
what to wear
what can you tell us about this wizard I
could take you to his castle beyond that
you are the ones intent I'm dying to run
run
she's an angel come to save us all
never seen anyone fight like that
you're a Wanderer
we have to kill them before they kill us
if the only way to stop their Invasion
catch you said you wanted to prove
yourself this is the time
evil is as Unstoppable as the rain
that's why we fight for those that can't
a good man knows that the darkness will
always be there and stands against it
anyway
[Music]
foreign